that's not the plan
no I was going to say though like listen
like bullying is real like self-esteem
is a real thing like it out okay so the
social media thing is a real thing
because I got a taste of it when I was
pregnant so it was kind of like this
[__] sucked for sure I can only imagine
because I really saw some [__] I did not
want to see when I was pregnant like the
whole time not like start to finish like
oh yeah
it's [__] you don't [__] you don't
forget like because yeah the internet
will forget but it's you personally will
never ever ever like get off you right
like even if you if that one person
bring it up oh I'm gonna suck you in
your mouth my thing is is like we all
take in comments a certain way but no
matter what they might
I don't
I come to like I watch him so I kind of
like okay so like because there's plenty
of things they say about him and it's
like oh that's so cat like it's so kept
to like where his point I'm like okay
now I know the internet is ridiculous
are you getting like um hate DMs like
crazy people saying hey I've had like
six Instagrams all her Instagram every
single one they delete them they just
flag you yep why the [__]
I don't even know I've made like six in
the last month
Rock Hive coming for you yeah
I think it's her personally but I think
no no it's her fans it's just a pickup
she has a very heart like she has like
we did that interview I saw it and that
just kind of gives like what type of
females is out there like yeah so you're
on that that's probably why you don't
like it and me personally like if I
don't agree with what you doing or how
you doing it I'm not going like hype you
up I'm gonna be the first to be like nah
you know
so that's why me and her kind of like
fell out like I don't agree with a lot
of things so it's like I can't co-sign
it came out for it you at the club
pregnant eight months like falling off
it's just like bro I can't how can I
defense that like Baby yeah I don't care
how much money they paying you it's not
worth it's not worth it yeah make the
money don't let it make you like I don't
care how much somebody pays me I
couldn't do nothing
homosexually feel me
how much how much weight of a 10 billion
dollars nothing bro if they gave me a
billion say hey yo kiss bootleg camera
[__] you wait a billion dollars I
wouldn't kiss you that's crazy for a
billion dollars I'm kissing you for a
billion that's what I'm saying like for
a billion dollars I'll kiss blue so this
is yeah that's the difference for a
billion dollars
the principal [__] the principal it's 20
23 give me my bills I don't know maybe
because I don't know I mean
I never hear from me again I understand
both sides I understand both sides I'll
never knock the hustle for me I've never
took a shamrock on any type of contract
pause this one bro I've never put crush
on any type of contract any type of
paperwork I'm like it's not about that I
could have I could have had her sign her
whole life away but that I don't want
that you see me I don't want your life
do you you're somebody who we don't ever
really get to see like the super
vulnerable side of do you get to do you
see some of the [__] that gets said
about you whether it's a misconception I
see I see everything but I'm saying do
you like
you're never gonna deal with a publicly
but does it ever get to you
yeah I mean I see everything here it
never gets to me I just try to try to
turn it into money same thing I did with
her
I didn't write her song but I
constructively oh they talking about
this I had this too you know they
talking about that add that to this this
is more
you know if you can feel it you can feel
it if you can see it you can see it this
is easier that way